[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
Welcome to the fourth episode
of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy, and I'm
here with my co-host, Mark.
Hi, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing well, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty
good, pretty good.
Trying to fight the jet lag.
What about you?
Where are you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
in San Francisco.
It's relatively early
on a Saturday morning
here in my living room.
That's a great place to be.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a nice place to be.
Well, I'm--
MARK MANDEL: Where
are you hiding?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
actually hiding somewhere
in the south of France.
I'm on my way from
Paris to Barcelona,
where I'll be next week.
MARK MANDEL: OK, that
sounds really, really fun.
Sounds like you're
going your travel on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Saturday
afternoon podcast recording.
Fun.
MARK MANDEL: Fun.
Well, that's pretty exciting.
So we have a Back to
the Future moment.
We have an interview
that's going to come up
that hasn't even been done yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so actually, I'm
going to Barcelona, as I said.
I'm going there for
Dockercon, where I
will be giving a lengthy talk.
But even more
important than that,
I will be interviewing
Jessie Frazelle, one
of the contributors--
well, actually,
one of the team members
of Docker engine team.
She's going to be
talking to us-- I hope,
because I still don't know.
But she will be talking
to us about containers,
what's all the fuss about
and how you get started.
MARK MANDEL: It
sounds like that's
going to be a really
interesting interview.
I look forward to
listening to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I look
forward to actually doing
that interview.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Wonderful.
So we have, I think, a
pretty cool cool thing
of the week this week,
and definitely something
that sits in your wheelhouse
because it has to do with Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it does.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we
released the Google Cloud
Debugger for Go recently.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Which is, in my opinion,
a great thing to have.
I could not have named
that because first time I
heard about a debugger
on production,
I was slightly scared about
having breakpoints on my--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that does sound scary.
I'm just going to
start my processes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But
it doesn't do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It doesn't
do that at all, actually.
So basically what the
Cloud Debugger does,
both for Java and Go-- we have
it for both languages now--
is that for any application that
is running on Google Compute
Engine, you basically
set it up first,
and then it will allow
you to add break points.
But actually, those are
not real break points.
Those are snapshot points.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, so it
takes a picture of what's
going on in your
system so you can
see what's happening
with your variables
and your call stack
and things like that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
So you can add some conditions.
So you don't want to
take any snapshot.
For instance, you
can say, oh yeah,
once you take a snapshot of
this line, these four low point,
the index variable
is 42, and that's it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
That's actually really powerful.
That's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's really powerful.
It will allow you to see
what is the value of all
the variables in the
scope at that point,
and also the call stack.
So you'll be able to understand
not only what you're doing,
but also how you got there.
So that's very powerful, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So I
haven't played with it,
but I'm guessing people are
going to be like is there
a performance issue here?
Is there something, you know,
I'm running this in production.
Is that a problem?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
actually not a problem.
Taking snapshots will have
a very, very tiny impact
on your performance.
But it's actually good enough
that if you have an issue,
I could definitely not
even think about it.
Just go for it.
Try it.
For sure, don't leave it on,
taking snapshots every second
because it's not really useful.
But it's something
that it's definitely
worth the performance cost.
Because also, the
performance cost
is only linked to the point
when you actually use it.
When you're not using it, you
don't have a performance cost.
So you're good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And obviously, that
performance cost
is worth it to solve
whatever that issue is
that you're having.
And if you have to
do it on production,
it's probably a
really tricky issue.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
It's basically on the order of
nine inches of milliseconds.
Like I don't know if
it's like around five
milliseconds or
something like that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
is definitely worth it.
There's worse things that could
happen to your production,
really.
And it's going to allow
you to basically find
the good values for you
to test on your code
outside of production.
And then in there, you can
actually use an actual debugger
and go step-by-step
understand what's exactly
the problem with the code.
Or even better, run a bunch
of unit tests demonstrating
that your code is wrong.
Then fix it and fix
your test with that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, that sounds-- yeah.
Sometimes there are just
those tricky issues,
like race conditions that
you couldn't bring up
in unit tests are tricky
to bring up in your tests
or you didn't think of,
stuff that really, like,
it only shows up in
production, because that's
the best place for things
to show up, obviously.
But these things happen.
So it's good to have
those sort of tools.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's good that
you mention race conditions.
It's actually something that
I've been talking lately about.
So when you have race
conditions in Go,
one of the best
things that you can do
is use the data waste
detector, which is as simple--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--is as simple to use
as when you build your
binary dash, dash race.
That's it.
That's everything
you need to do.
And then it generates
a binary that
will detect any
time that there's
a race detect-- data race.
When that happens--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --it
will emit a warning.
So with that, then, you can,
basically every single time
such a warning appears,
you can analyze your logs
and file a bug or something like
that so that you can fix it.
If you do that, though,
you have to be careful,
because it's not like--
it doesn't take snapshots.
It's actually much slower.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
it's kind of slow?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
will slow down your process
quite a bit, even though
when there's no data erases.
Which means that it's
something that you
might want to do
as a side server,
like you have a test server that
it's getting maybe some shadow
traffic from production
and he's actually
trying to handle those.
And if it takes longer,
it's not really fun
because it's not impacting
the production traffic.
It's just getting
some of that traffic
and if something goes wrong,
files the bug directly.
So that's also a very
useful technique.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
There you.
Go one cloud thing,
one cool Go thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
MARK MANDEL: Extra cool thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [LAUGHS] Great,
so I think that it's probably
time to bring Jessie
from the future
and start talking with
her about containers.
What do you think?
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
Excited to hear it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so we're
here with Jessie Frazelle.
Hi, Jessie.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Hi. [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we're here at Dockercon,
and so that's the
Dockercon EU in Barcelona,
the second Dockercon
that has happened?
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
Yes, so the second
of the European conferences.
There's also two that
happened in the US.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So we've been here.
It is the second day,
and as far as I've seen,
Jessie is not only
well-known in the Docker
community in San Francisco, but
pretty much everywhere else.
So I wanted to know
a little bit more
about what you do at
Docker to be so famous?
[LAUGHTER]
JESSIE FRAZELLE: I'm not famous.
I am a core maintainer, so
I think that actually that
has a lot to do with it.
It's an open source project and
it gets a lot of visibility.
And I also am contributing
a lot of code for it.
Most recently have been working
on adding setConf to Docker
itself, which a lot
of people have wanted.
And I helped try to get
in the username space pull
requests, which was
also heavily requested.
So yeah, we work a
lot on [LAUGHS] Go
and open source, in general.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I saw that there
was some statistics
about the number of pull
requests that you get per week.
How many are those?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: We get
around 200 for a week,
and actually we have--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
My god. [LAUGHS]
JESSIE FRAZELLE: --like
even cooler stats.
My coworker Arnaud wrote
this really cool Go
to that will get all
the open source stats.
And I found out that I am
the person who closes, not
merges, the most pull requests.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So maybe
that's why you're famous.
That's maybe not such
a good thing after all.
[LAUGHTER]
And how long you've
been working at Docker?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: A little
bit over a year now.
I started in September,
but my first contribution
was last June-- er, like
the June before that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, nice.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
that's how I became a--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's great.
So how did you get
started with containers?
Containers have been
something really important
like the new, hot
thing in the tech
industry for quite a while.
Why did you get
interested on it?
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
So the startup I
was working at before,
Docker, we actually used LXE.
And LXE, it works, but it's
just kind of painful to use.
So we switched a
Docker at 0.5, which
was kind of rough, but
still better than LXE.
So then I started
getting into the project.
I started watching the repo,
and one thing led to another.
And here I am.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very cool.
So you started using
Docker a little bit
because you were already
using containers.
LXE is kind of like containers,
just not as easy to use,
basically.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Totally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why
did someone start
using containers as a company?
What is the benefit of running
containers rather than just
everything directly
on bare metal?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: So it
allows your infrastructure
to be easily transported
from dev into production,
because you can
run it on your Mac.
You can run it anywhere.
And actually, in the first
keynote at Dockercon,
they showed a new developer
starting on their first day.
All they have to spin
up on their laptop
is Docker itself
instead sort of having
to get like the
whole company stack,
like Python, Ruby,
all that crap.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's very nice.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
It's way easier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
basically getting, like,
the development environment
inside of the container also.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool.
So I think that rather than
spending time talking about why
people should move to
containers-- because
at this point, I'm pretty
sure that most of people
actually think that that's a
good idea-- I'd like to talk
about how do you do that.
So if you were to move a
company from a traditional stack
to containers, what
could be the first steps?
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
Yeah, so I would
say it would be to start taking
apart your monolithic things
into the database, running
that in a container by itself,
whatever proxy you have
running that in a container.
So just really separating
out the microservices.
And then, starting
to play around with,
maybe, the Docker command line,
and then maybe playing around
with the new like
platform as a service
tools, all these
different things that
have come to fruition.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, last week we
had an interview
with Brian Dorsey.
He worked for the
Kubernetes team.
And he was quite interesting,
because he was basically
talking about, yeah, once you
go through that step of going
from one monolithic app to
you have, all of a sudden,
a bunch of containers and
microservices and everything.
All of a sudden, there's a new
set of problems that set in.
So basically that's
when you're going
to be talking about Swarm
or Kubernetes or Mesos
or whatever stack
that you want to use.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: And there's
so many to choose from now.
It's like the world
is at your disposal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's really cool.
It's kind of scary.
I think that at some point we
should have an episode talking
about what to do.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah. [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
are the options there?
I think it's a quite
interesting topic.
So you mentioned
at the beginning
of the talk, the beginning
of the interview,
you mentioned setConf.
Security is quite a big deal.
I've seen people putting
private keys inside
of containers and
on public repos.
That's kind of dangerous.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Tell us a little bit
about what do you think
that we should always
take care of regarding
security with containers.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah, so
what I'm working on right
now is, the first
phase is actually
setConf itself, which is allow
or denying certain sys calls.
You can actually even
trace, et cetera.
But the first phase
is actually going
to be like this kind of
not so easy to use config,
but not so complex as
something as AppArmor
or something like that.
But the second phase
of that is actually
one config to rule
all security profiles,
and then it will have different
back ends, like using setConf
or AppArmor or SELinux label.
So you get the ability to
log on right on any file
or deny files being
written to allow
certain executables to run
like Petri, stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So basically, the idea is
that, the same way we have like
with OS/2, you
have scopes and you
allow people to do one
thing or the other-- it's
kind of the same thing,
but inside of Linux, right?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
Totally.
It was actually designed and
inspired by the Apple APIs
and also Android's APIs
for security scopes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah, I saw your demo,
your Linux talk, at not
[INAUDIBLE], but the
Docker meet-up in Belgium.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was really interesting.
I wonder if that was recorded.
If it was recorded,
I'll try to put a link
to that on the show notes.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Oh, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm going to say
it again, but you're
kind of famous for one specific
thing, which is running
everything in a container.
Like, I've seen you're running
normal things like Chrome,
but also I've seen you
even launching games
from Steam on a container,
which is pretty awesome.
And it's really amazing the fact
that you're able to do that.
People tend to say, oh
yeah, that's too hard.
But then you make it look easy.
So I wanted to ask you, what
is the next crazy thing you're
going to do?
Or if there's no crazy
thing that can disclose,
what is one crazy
thing that you've
tried and totally failed?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: So
my coworker Arnaud
and I gave a talk
yesterday, and we
had this crazy idea of fitting
a Docker image onto a 1.44
megabyte floppy disk.
And it was all going
to go so perfectly.
I ordered this floppy
disk to USB converter,
and I translated the
page from Spanish
so that I could make sure
that it ran on Linux.
And I plugged it
in when we got it,
and it was just
like totally borked,
like back in the olden
days when you would
put in your floppy
disk and you just
knew it wasn't working right.
It was like the
exact same sound.
So we were like,
well, [BLEEP], but we
did create an image that was
small enough to fit on one.
And the coolest part
about it, actually,
was that the binary
that was in the image
was a Go binary built statically
so we could build from scratch.
And the binary itself
was, like, 5 megabytes,
which is way too big.
It's never going to fit.
But then when you put
it in the Docker image
itself and you do a Docker
save, it will create a tarball,
but that tarball
isn't compressed.
So actually, what we did was
untar it, then retar it with XZ
and nine compression,
the maximum.
And it was 1.3 megabytes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So that's actually
very interesting.
Can you actually
do that in general?
Once you have that
Docker image untarred
and then tar it
with compression,
then the Docker daemon
will be able to handle it
like if it was a normal image?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
So that XZ compressed
image, I could
have Docker loaded it back in.
So it actually would be
really nice if on Docker save
we could pass a flag, like
use this compression level,
like either Gzip, XZ,
and like what sort of.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that'd be really nice.
Because nowadays one of
the problems that I have
is if I try to run
Docker on my machine
and I have hotel Wi-Fi
or conference Wi-Fi.
It's kind of a pain because
images tend to be quite big.
So that could maybe
help with that.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah, totally.
That would be a huge help.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty awesome.
The other option, of course,
is using Docker machine.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which-- yeah.
There's actually-- we'll put on
the links one of my coworkers,
[INAUDIBLE], wrote a
blog post about how
to use Docker with
the conference Wi-Fi.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Oh my
god, that's so good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
basically you started instance
somewhere like in
Google Cloud platform
and then you connect to that.
And it works
really, really well.
That's what I do
all the time now.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: That's perfect.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So you mentioned something that
didn't work-- the floppy disk.
Tell us about something
that you think
is cool that you've seen lately.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Cool.
Yeah, so actually the stuff
with X server that I do
is all just mounting
locally my X11 socket,
but you can also actually
do this entirely remote
on a server.
So say you have
Wireshark, which has
like a GUI running on a server.
You can have remote
VNC connection
and actually show it locally
on your local instance.
So I think that
that's kind of neat.
And also the fact that
you can-- the difference
between VMs and containers
is sharing name spaces.
So the fact that you can
have a Wireshark container
connected to a
different container
sharing the same
network name space,
you can actually look
at all the packets
from the other container
without exposing everything
from your host to the
Wireshark container itself.
So just the fact that Docker
allows you to share .NET
namespaces, PID namespaces,
it's super helpful in terms
of debugging.
And the whole
remote VNC 11 thing
is also helpful in
terms of debugging.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So there's two
really cool things in there.
One is the fact that--
so what you're saying
is that you have your containers
that it's running somewhere
and that it's not aware
of Wireshark or anything,
just running there.
You won't have to debug it.
And without modifying
find that container,
you're able to start a new
container that will be sniffing
those packets with Wireshark?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
so you can actually
take the network namespace
from the container
that you want to debug and then
run the next container-- let's
say your Watershark container,
or like maybe even a strace
container in that
network namespace.
And if it was strace,
you could actually
run it in the PID namespace
of the other container, which
is really--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really powerful.
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
It's fascinating.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's really powerful.
So basically, you can connect
to that container, the container
that you want to
investigate that and need
to know anything you
need to restart it
or anything to
just connect there.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: So it
annihilates the whole need
to like exec in,
install other [BLEEP],
and then do what you need to do.
You don't need to exec anymore.
You can be sure that your
debugging tools won't
modify the original container.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: And, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that
was one of the cool things.
The other cool thing
that that implies
is that you can be running
graphical UIs, QAs, on a server
and access them like if
they were local applications
on your laptop.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Right.
So that's through X server,
which means that on Linux it
works really well.
What about Mac?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
Mac would be interesting.
I think it would probably have
to use maybe the same hack that
is used when people try to
run my stuff on their Macs,
and it involves a socat into
like an X11 Mac instance,
and then it fires into to VM.
I'm not really sure on
the technical details,
but it's something
like magic. [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds quite complicated.
Is there are any
blockbuster something
that you could point us to?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
there is actually
an issue that is closed now.
But on Docker
itself where someone
is mentioning MyGUI
apps, and I think
it's titled like Mac OSX X11,
and the person who figured it
out posted all of the details.
And actually, I'll
get emails still
on this issue of people thanking
the guy who figured it out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
It must still work
and it must still be legit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
so I'll check it out,
and I'll add that
link also to the show.
That sounds really interesting.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So do you think it
could be then doable
to have something
like you have a
pretty small computer,
like a tiny micro computer,
or even Raspberry Pi, maybe.
Imagine that you
have a Raspberry Pi
and you want to run a quite
powerful application that
requires CPU.
Could you be doing
something where you just
have your X11 server
running on the Raspberry Pi,
and then the rest of
computation is actually
sent to some container
running somewhere else?
And you can have, like
in Google Could Platform,
you can have like 32
course, if you want to.
So you could be running like a
very, very powerful opposition.
And it could look like it's
running on the Raspberry Pi?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah, totally.
I mean you could
use VNC and do that,
and yeah, that would actually
be a really cool idea,
especially in terms of the
whole conference Wi-Fi thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: You just have
the most minimal stuff locally,
and then everything else is
just hitting a remote instance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
will definitely try that.
That sounds actually
really interesting.
Cool.
So to finish, I wanted
to talk a little bit more
about your relationship
with the Docker community.
So you said that you
started working as a-- well,
you started contributing
before you were an employee.
What is your
relationship with-- what
is the relationship of Docker
with other contributors?
How many do you have?
How do you handle them?
Other than closing
their PRs [INAUDIBLE].
JESSIE FRAZELLE: [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How do
you manage that community,
basically?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah, so
a lot of our communication
is over IRC.
We have a channel
just for maintainers,
which is where we take care of
more like administrative tasks.
And then there's the
Dock dev channel,
where which is where we have
the bots talking about open PRs,
we have maintainers
coming in asking us
how they should
implement something,
or contributors being like I
hit this while to build Docker.
Its very, like, only
developing to Dockers,
which is really cool.
And then also we
have a ton of bots
on the repo that help us out in
terms of just the sheer volume
of poll requests we get.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
We were thinking
of looking into what
Kubernetes' bot is,
because it looks really cool.
Yeah, I mean, it's actually
really cool, especially
the Docker core team that is
employed by the Docker as well,
because every single one of us
was contributing to the project
before we worked there.
So as much as people say Docker
is this enterprise company,
like we are not.
If anything, everyone
else at Docker
thinks of us as
the hipster kids.
So we're also very
opinionated ourselves,
and it's nice to know that we
all came from the community
first.
So if anything, my
love for the project
will always exceed
anything else.
I want the project
to be good, and I
want it to be something
I want to use personally.
And it is something
that I use personally.
So I mean, I think it's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Use every day
with every single application
you run.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So just to have an idea,
how many maintainers,
how many contributors
do you have?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
Contributors, there's,
like, in the thousands.
It's actually gotten so big
that GitHub won't show them all
if you go on that page.
It will only show the
top whatever they show.
So there's a ton.
Maintainers, there's maintainers
of the various subsets
of Docker itself.
But for the Docker
engine, I would
say there's definitely five
from Docker the company,
and then there's about 10
external from various companies
like IBM, Red Hat, and then also
just individuals themselves,
which is really cool.
And students at universities,
even, are maintainers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That's very nice.
OK, so to finish
the interview, I
had two questions which is
about the coolest things
that you've seen.
So what is the
coolest talk or what's
the coolest thing you've
learned during Dockercon?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Oh, man.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: This Dockercon.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: So this talk
that I was just at, actually,
this guy was talking about
how they run Honeypots
in containers on their
servers, and I was just like,
that's a really cool
concept. [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
For the listeners
that doesn't know
what a Honeypot is--
because it's not a pot with
honey-- what is a Honeypot?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: It's put there
to kind of try to catch hackers
as like a hey, come.
This might be open for you.
But you don't really
go into details
as to what exactly
theirs were doing,
but it was just
interesting that they one,
run them in containers--
which is awesome.
But two, they just
have them spread out
all their infrastructure
everywhere.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So it's basically a way
of monitoring if someone
is actually attacking?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really smart.
I really like it.
And the other cool thing is,
what is the coolest feature
of Docker for you?
What's the thing that
you love the most?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: I mean,
I love all features.
But Docker exec,
for some reason,
it means something
personally to me.
Because it was like my first
week working at Docker.
And granted, I had contributed
to the project before.
But it was a feature
that I really wanted.
But two, I got
assigned to it to try
to help it through the process.
And it was actually Vish from
Google who wrote the PR itself.
And then I got to merge it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: So it was
super exciting and fun.
And it was like two
days before my birthday.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
a birthday present.
That's a very geeky
birthday present, really.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: It's so good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Nice.
Well, thank you so much
for taking your time
to talk with us.
And see you somewhere else
in a different conference.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah, thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So thank you
very much to you, Francesc,
for setting up the interview,
and Jessie for joining us.
I'm sure when I listen to
the episode in the future
it will be amazing.
I know both of you are amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
thank you, Jessie,
for taking the time off a very,
very busy week a Dockercon
to have a chat with us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
we have a great question
of the week from one of
our previous listeners
and one time answer
providers, a gentleman
by the name of Terrence
who's a technical solutions
engineer here at Google.
He asks a good question, like
a debugging style question,
which I quite like, which is
sort of this situation where
it's like why can't my Google
Compute Engine instance connect
to a particular API resource,
like Cloud SQL of big query,
or Cloud Datastore?
And it could be something
that I think has probably
bitten me a couple times.
So I think it's an
excellent question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, I've seen that before
and I've heard people
asking those questions before.
So I think it's a great
question of the week.
So the answer is
actually quite simple.
It's security.
By default, when you create an
instance on a computer engine,
the instance will not have
access to all the things
that you could do.
So it will have access
to some of the resources
that we also call scopes.
So, for instance,
what you create it,
it would have read only
access to Google Cloud Storage
but won't be able to write.
So what do you do if
you want that instance
to be able to write?
MARK MANDEL: So
the easiest way is
if you're creating an instance
through the development
through the console,
through the web console.
If you go to a tab when you
create an instance called
access and security, you'll see
all the levels of API access
you have there.
And as you said, you can
see the Cloud SQL is none.
BigQuery is none by default.
Storage is read only.
Because security, right?
Like you want to keep
things locked down
and only open up the things
you want to, which is great.
And that that's
a really easy way
of saying oh, when I created
that instance before,
maybe I forgot to turn this on.
Maybe I should go have a look.
It's sort of a
very common gotcha.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Though,
I do like the fact
that now there is
a button there that
says allow API access to
all Google Cloud services.
That's pretty handy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's pretty handy,
but I could not advise
using it as a general basis.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
it's very good if you
want to have an
instance that you want
to test that your code
is actually correct
and it's just an access problem.
Or if you are actually
using that instance
to do a development
it's a great idea.
But it's definitely not
a good security policy
to allow access
to all the scopes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
I think it's a great
troubleshooting feature.
You know, like let's make
sure that this isn't something
that the problem
with what's going on.
And then I can go
back and say OK,
let's scale these security
measures back and make
sure everything is
the way it should be.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Something interesting than maybe
some of our users will know
is in the screen that
you were talking about
before, when you create a
dialog, where you create
an instance, there's
actually at the button,
if I remember correctly,
something like equivalent REST
API?
Or something like that?
Or an equivalent GCloud command.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
Whoa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that will actually
show you how to do the same
thing through either the REST
API, so it's going
to be a JSON object,
or with a Gigolo command.
So that can be quite useful.
What you want to do is create
that instance with this code
that you need from a place
other than the console itself.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's nice.
I'm actually
looking at that now.
I didn't quite realize
that was there.
I think I probably
knew, but I'd forgotten.
But that's like a nice
interactive documentation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
a very useful thing,
because sometimes I don't
remember exactly, especially
in the JSON formats, like,
oh, where does it go?
What is the parameter into
GCloud to create this thing?
So it's very, very handy.
MARK MANDEL: That's
very, very cool.
I like that a lot.
So yeah, if you happen
to run into a situation
where you think you've
got your code right
but for whatever
reason you can't access
Cloud SQL or something like
that from Compute Engine,
make sure you're going
to check your scopes,
see if you have access that
way, because you may not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Very good.
So to wrap up, I would like to
know what are you up to next?
Where are you going to be doing?
MARK MANDEL: What am
I going to be doing?
So when this episode
actually comes out
I will be at
[INAUDIBLE] this time.
I think you and I are
doing very similar talks
in just different places.
We're talking about
wrecking developer tooling
in Docker containers,
which is kind of funny.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Definitely a hot topic lately.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Look, you just got to
put container on it
and then you're fine.
That's pretty much
what I've come down to.
But no, that's great.
And then in December
I will be it
at DevFest in Vancouver,
December 12th and 13th.
If you're in the
area, come on down.
There will be several
of us, be a few DAs,
so it should be a good time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds like lots of fun.
So on my side, I will
actually, by the time
these episode comes
up, I will still
be in Barcelona, the last
day of the Dockercon.
So that's where I'm heading.
Tomorrow I'm going to
Barcelona for Dockercon.
And that's pretty much it.
But I actually just
wanted to mention also
that I just came back
from Devoxx, where
one of our
colleagues-- so Devoxx
in Belgium, one
of our colleagues
gave an amazing demonstration
of Kubernetes, which
we talked about last week.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah,
heard about this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, on a cluster
of Raspberry Pi's, which is
an amazing demonstration.
You can basically unplug
cables and see how parts
get reallocated and so on.
It's an amazing demo,
so I will say if you
have a minute, go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: OK, great.
We'll have to put the
video in the show notes.
That sounds fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank
you once again, Francesc,
for joining me for recording.
Much appreciated.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, thank you, Mark,
for waking up so early.
I also appreciate it.
It was a great pleasure
talking to you,
so see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]